[Musik]
nachrichten des tages heute nichts
barbara hahlweg
guten abend schön dass sie dabei sind
wie auch norbert lehmann und für den
sport genannte von mir ein wichtiger tag
bei unseren nachbarn
frankreich hat die wahl im rennen um die
präsidentschaft zeichnet sich ein duell
ab zwischen amtsinhaber makro und der
rechtspopulistin le pen
immer neue massengräber die ukraine
spricht inzwischen von mehr als 1200
toten in der region ihre
flagge zeigen für russland in mehreren
deutschen städten gehen pro russische
demonstranten auf die straße
[Musik]
frankreich wählt und europa bank denn es
ist nicht mehr auszuschließen dass am
ende die rechtspopulistin marine le pen
gewinnt der klare umfrage vorsprung von
präsident marco ist deutlich geschrumpft
heute können die wähler zwischen 12
kandidatinnen und kandidaten entscheiden
deren politisches spektrum reicht von
ganz links bis ganz rechts die beiden
mit den meisten stimmen kommen dann in
die stichwahl in zwei wochen favoriten
sind makro und le pen aus paris an
er tritt an für eine zweite amtszeit
frankreichs präsident manual marco will
das land weiter reformieren setzt sich
für ein starkes europa ein in umfragen
lag er zuletzt vorn doch nur knapp wegen
des ukraine krieg hat er kaum wahlkampf
geführt
es war eine besondere kampagne sie war
sehr kurz der präsident ist erst spät
eingestiegen und ich glaube die leute
warten ab bis zur stichwahl
wir sind alle etwas verloren mit dem
angebot aber wir müssen wählen
enthaltung ist keine option
dennoch bis zum nachmittag fiel die
beteiligung um vier prozentpunkte
geringer aus als bei der letzten wahl
das könnte den radikalen kandidaten zu
gute kommen deren wähler als besonders
engagiert gelten
so holte markus stärkste herausforderung
marine le pen in den umfragen immer mehr
auf die rechtspopulistin setzt auf die
stimmen der unzufriedenen auf soziale
themen wie wohnen und arbeit wobei sie
franzosen vor rechte einräumen will sie
steht für einen europaskeptischen kurs
ebenso wie der kandidat vom radikal
linken rand so lieb melange sein
programm mehr mindestlohn rente schon ab
60 und austritt aus der nato er wird auf
platz 3 gesehen doch deutlich hinter
lippen und makro die extrem rechte ist
im moment sehr stark in frankreich ich
werde alles daran setzen dass sie nicht
durchkommt es gibt viele viele leute die
in der stichwahl marine le pen werden
würden um nicht mag ort zu wählen
tabuthema crew die entscheidung wer
frankreich künftig führen soll ist auch
eine entscheidung über die zukunft
europas
herr thomas weiter in paris was sind die
ersten tendenzen und was steht auf dem
spiel
also dass die wahlbeteiligung in diesem
jahr niedriger ist als vor fünf jahren
und auch vor zehn jahren bestätigt im
grunde den eindruck den man vor der wahl
hatte dass es einen enthusiasmus problem
gibt dass einige kandidaten ein
mobilisierungsproblem haben
überdurchschnittlich war die
wahlbeteiligung demnach heute etwa im
wahlkreis von marine le pen
unterdurchschnittlich war sie hier in
paris was gemeinhin als hochburg emanuel
makros gilt daraus kann man jetzt noch
keinen landesweiten trend ablesen aber
es zeigt das kann heute abend eine sehr
enge geschichte werden ein sehr knappes
ergebnis werden das kann auch in den
kommenden zwei wochen bis zur stichwahl
sehr knapp werden und wegen der doch
sehr unterschiedlichen positionen der
hauptkandidaten hier bei diesen
präsidentschaftsrennen macht das einmal
mehr deutlich dass es nicht nur für
frankreich um sehr viel geht sondern
auch für die deutsch französischen
beziehungen für den zusammenhalt in der
europäischen union und auch in der nato
dankeschön für diese einschätzung aus
paris thomas weiterer das
jetzt zum krieg in einem telefonat mit
dem bundeskanzler hat der ukrainische
präsident seelands geht die verfolgung
der kriegsverbrechen und weitere
sanktionen gefordert bei kiew wurden
neue massengräber entdeckt in der ost
ukraine versuchen sich die menschen auf
eine weitere russische offensive
vorzubereiten der freie journalist und
ginzel ist dort unterwegs sein bericht
erreicht uns aus der stadt
wir sind unterwegs von reaktiv richtung
osten richtung front wir wollen das
letzte krankenhaus auf ukrainischem
gebiet besuchen direkt davor ist eine
rakete eingeschlagen
als wir mit den dreharbeiten beginnen
wollen gibt es luftalarm
wir müssen raus aus dem ort von zwei
soldaten die an uns rausgeholt aus der
klinik es wurden chats gesehen haben am
himmel russische kampfflugzeuge
wir fahren in ein wohnviertel hier ist
vor einer woche eine russische granate
eingeschlagen es war die wohnung von
wladimir trikot er lebt jetzt mit seinen
nachbarn im keller
die soll es einem gehen wenn man
permanent beschossen wird natürlich habe
ich angst meine ehefrau bist ums leben
gekommen
heute morgen ist seine frau im
krankenhaus gestorben erzählt er uns
gestorben an den verletzungen die sie
beim angriff auf ihre wohnung erlitten
hat
der ort ist immer noch umkämpft
zwischen ukraine und russen
wir fahren nach archiv zum krankenhaus
in dem seine frau gestorben ist sind
verabredet mit dem sohn er wünscht sich
dass der krieg endlich aufhört hat
der krieg hat schon so vielen menschen
das leben gekostet auch das leben meiner
mama den menschen den ich am meisten
geliebt habe
nur ein schicksal von tausenden in
diesem krieg gegen die zivilbevölkerung
trotz dieser grausamkeit und trotz all
der kriegsverbrechen gab es heute wieder
in mehreren deutschen städten
pro-russische kundgebungen und
autokorsos unter strengen auflagen und
oft begleitet von gegendemos aus
hannover christina eglseder es sind etwa
650 russischsprachige menschen die sich
am mittag in hannover versammelt um
gegen eine angebliche diskriminierung zu
demonstrieren wir sind nicht hier um
über den krieg zu sprechen und für die
medien möchte ich das selber noch mal
sagen dass unser thema heute nicht der
krieg ist sondern die diskriminierung
die uns gegenüber hier in deutschland
wieder fährt und das schon seit mehreren
jahren und erst recht seit kurzem einen
vorwand sagen experten vielmehr gehe es
darum sympathien für den russischen
angriffskrieg kundzutun
etwa jeder fünfte der hier lebenden
russischsprachigen menschen ist laut
studien empfänglich für die propaganda
aus moskau
das ist eine minderheit der großen
russischsprachigen gruppe in deutschland
eine kleine minderheit aber eine
sichtbare und aktive minderheit da wird
das der erzählung putins gefolgt es gebe
keinen krieg in der ukraine es gebe
keine verbrechen an den zivilisten die
polizei angewiesen konsequent vorzugehen
gegen verbotene fahnen oder das zeigen
des sexsymbols
wir geben allen die freiheit sich zu
äußern ihre meinung zu äußern solange
sie nicht in freiheit ein anderer
eingreifen beziehungsweise gegen
strafgesetze verstoßen zeitgleich zum
prorussischen autokorso mehrere
gegendemos dreieinhalb tausend menschen
die ein zeichen setzen wollen für die
ukraine wir werden uns auch gegen diesen
autokorso der sehr leicht als
unterstützung des angriffskriegs
gewertet werden kann die blau gelben
fahnen heute in hannover jedenfalls
deutlich in der mehrheit
cdu-chef märz fordert die entlassung von
bundesfamilienministerin spiegel als
rheinland-pfälzische umweltministerin
hatte sie zehn tage nach der
flutkatastrophe im aartal einen
vierwöchigen urlaub angetreten es
beweise sich erneut dass für frau
spiegel urlaub und das eigene image
wichtiger gewesen sein als das schicksal
der menschen an der ahr schrieb märz auf
twitter
vor 77 jahren wurde das
konzentrationslager buchenwald von der
us-armee befreit unterstützt von
aufständischen häftlingen an der
gedenkveranstaltung nahmen erstmals seit
beginn der korona pandemie auch wieder
kz-überlebende teil unter ihnen
anastasia dollar aus der ukraine die 96
jährige ist nach dem russischen angriff
nach deutschland geflogen
die taz zitiert sie mit den worten ich
habe hitler überlebt und stalin ich
werde auch putin überleben
hat er schnitt jetzt noch wird sport zur
formel1 schale claire gewinnt den großen
preis von australien ein souveräner
start ziel sieg des ferrari-piloten
weltmeister max verstappen dagegen
schied wegen eines technischen defekts
aus ja und auch kein guter tag für
sebastian vettel
gerät auf einen randstein beschleunigt
dann bricht das heck aus beim einschlag
sein kopf richtung lenkrad enorme kräfte
wirken eine medizinische untersuchung
ist die folge ja so weit gut ich glaube
wenn der einschlag heftiger ist als 15
geht dann geht ein lämpchen und dann
gehört das zur routine mit schumacher
wird dreizehnter auch durch dieses
wichtige manöver überholt seinen
teamkollegen kevin magnussen für schale
claire rechts ist es ein start ziel sieg
von beginn an hat er die nase vorn auch
beim neustart nach einer safety car
phase wird er den angriff des
weltmeisters max verstappen im red bull
ab wenig später muss der niederländer
mit einer defekten benzinleitung am red
bull aufgeben lewis hamilton wird
vierter hadert mit reifen und motor
serie paris- links im red bull genauso
vor ihm wie teamkollege george russel
schale claire gewinnt sein zweites
saisonrennen
im ersten sonntagsspiel der
fußball-bundesliga trennten sich bochum
und leverkusen 0 2 0 bayer bleibt
tabellendritter der vfl 1 runter auf
platz zwölf jessica von bredow werndl
hat gestern abend erstmals in ihrer
erfolgskarriere den dressur weltcup
gewonnen beim letzten großen turnier vor
ihrer babypause siegte die
doppel-olympiasiegerin in leipzig mit
ihrer stute dilara und letzter
gemeinsamer auftritt von dieser bild
wird mit weiher gold die 17 jährige
ausnahme ich gute verabschiedet sich in
den ruhestand zum abschied rang drei für
das erfolgsduo
das war sehr schön dankeschön galt das
wetter bringt sonne und wärme im
nordosten ein mix aus wolken und etwas
sonne sonst überwiegt der sonnenschein
im norden und osten 8 bis 14 im westen
und süden 14 bis 19 grad
bettina schausten hat um viertel vor
zehn im heute-journal schon zahlen aus
frankreich wir sagen tschüss bis morgen
wünschen ihnen einen guten start in die
neue woche und geben ab zu theo koll und
berlin direkt vielen dankbar war weg die
ukraine spricht heute von mittlerweile
5600 mutmaßlichen
was heißt das für den künftigen umgang
mit putin und was heißt das für die
leise tretende deutsche außenpolitik und
damit herzlich willkommen bei berlin
direkt